the stunning vistas of southern
california are once again
in flames this fire in orange county
exploded overnight
racing through silverado canyon and
raining ash on homes and farms
residents evacuated with their animals
and ran for their lives we heard screams
like fire fire it's it's right here so
we have to leave right now
i looked out the window and it was
already so big firefighters struggled
through steep terrain
trying to save these homes night flying
helicopters were in the air as was
the large helitanker currently there are
500 firefighters on the fire line
this one started with a house fire and
spread quickly
lighting up the night sky dangerous fire
conditions are in effect across much of
southern california
powerful santa ana winds and low
humidity making it easy for fires like
this
to burn out of control even if you don't
see smoke
you don't get the reverse 911 but
there's a concern you have a concern
that maybe the fire is a little too
close that's enough
that's enough to have your your
belongings prepared
and to evacuate once again utilities cut
electricity to tens of thousands of
southern california customers
in case the winds knock trees into power
lines
this is our sixth fire this year you
know the sixth one
california has already experienced its
worst year ever for wildfires
and with much of the state experiencing
drought this crisis appears
far from over chris martinez cbs news
orange california